when they bring up these asset classes I
want you to tell me the first thing that
comes to mind be as hilarious as you
want with it or okay because all right
so when someone says that you're
investing in the stock market right what
is that what comes to mind I just feel
panic and I I freak out because this is
all Beyond me so I just go whatever you
do it so like if a guy comes up he goes
I got a great opportunity you gotta
invest in this I'd be like all right all
right you could you could totally ruin
my life with some [ __ ] investment
opportunity I wouldn't fall for that in
a second and I have what is it about the
stock market is it the fact that it's
Bulls Bears UPS down left right green
red what is it that's intimidating I
think it's that you have no control over
it it changes every day even the idea of
stock like you own part of the company
that doesn't resonate with me I'm like I
don't I don't know what that means can I
do I have say can I can I fire up your
major shareholder oh really it'd be like
what happens if you owned one percent of
the comedy seller yeah I don't know what
that means do I get money yeah and I
lose money possibly okay well that that
helps a little and the better that the
comedians do the better jokes that are
being told the more money you make if
the comedians start bombing and everyone
sucks and everyone clears the room right
you start losing money ah okay okay and
it's weird that you get all panicky
about it because all the things you said
are just like comedy you have no control
over it you do you can write jokes you
can do nothing for sure but you have no
control over the environment you can
control how much money you put in or
take out but you don't know what the
response is going to be the cause and
effect that's true that's true but I can
go back home rewrite the joke listen to
the joke tweak it fix it I yeah I feel
like I have a little I get to decide
what's said up there you know so I feel
like I have a little more control I I
see what you're saying but uh the
business yeah I don't know the whole
thing it just sounds like I could sell
you anything I got a great investment
for you I would totally buy it uh
speaking of buying it you bought real
estate when you think of the real estate
market what comes to mind well that I
like because I can see it it's a
building it's a unit it's tangible yeah
and I can live in it too and I can rent
it and sure there's all this jargon with
the mortgage guy and I just go ah I
pretend to listen and he sends me a long
email and I pretend to read it and I go
yeah it looks great I don't know
anything it is you could totally screw
me over in the fine print but uh that at
least real estate I I could see it I
could touch it yeah so that helped you
could touch it it's tangible okay yeah
um crypto you said you invested in
crypto you can't touch that what are
your thoughts on crypto Bitcoin even
more elusive than stocks it's like it's
a coin but it's not a coin but it takes
up all this memory and Elon Musk and
it's out of China culture yeah it has
weird names he's in a turtle deck it's
too much if it was actually a coin I
might get it more yeah but the whole
point is that it's not a coin so you
can't get stolen I know you want to
touch it like real estate but you can't
but you gotta talk about it and it's you
know it's got cute little memes and
Dogecoin and Elon Musk right so but are
you more but if you had to pick one to
invest in long term would you be more
stock market or more crypto probably
more stuck just because it's older my
dad's heard of it you know Bitcoin is
like transgender like I pretend to get
it and then I just move on gotcha I
don't give them money speaking of crypto
and Bitcoin what are your thoughts on
nfts oh now we're getting even crazier
crazy it feels like there's trick me
yeah they probably are by the way
yeah they probably are
actually the way the ones that could
benefit you the most in your comedy and
you think yeah right the first joke
you've ever told your first tweets great
thought by Amber
okay I feel like nfts are on artist's
side the most that we can oh okay you
can I can it's my joke encapsulated as
an nft and then every time it's sold I
profit off of it as opposed to a YouTube
video that if you're not monetizing okay
great Adam am I learning yeah yeah I
don't know don't buy nfts in my opinion
oh really until you've saved money
invest in the stock market maybe done
some real estate and then start buying
like
Bitcoin or more I've used this word
traditional crypto assets yeah and then
maybe an nft it's all about asset
allocation
word you hear I don't think what do you
think the word asset allocation means
uh
uh I don't know breast implants yeah or
acid plants yeah I don't know what does
it mean well I mean they basically say
that everyone should have these days
with crypto I'll add this but asset
allocation is like you should have a
certain amount of cash
you shove a certain amount in stocks and
a certain amount in bonds those are like
the big three diversification I want to
blow your mind here Mark that's your
different asset allocation and then
within that
so like for me let's say I have a
million bucks let's just say all right
I've got a hundred grand in cash done
boom okay I've got it liquid liquid yeah
liquid
um
I've got let's say a half a million
dollars in Investments
what does that mean all right so that's
401K Roth IRA you know traditional stock
stuff and then a small sliver in bonds
I'm not a conservative guy so a little
of that and now let's say I've got you
know maybe it's a little bit more than
half a million so let's say six seven
hundred thousand so now the remaining 20
that's where you can kind of get a
little spunky all right maybe some
crypto maybe some Bitcoin maybe some you
know Forex Trading but for the majority
of people you should have cash yeah you
should have the stock market and then
you know obviously real estate like so
for instance I don't buy real estate I
don't like I don't need to touch it I
get the market so I don't need to like I
don't need to touch it I'm good I
actually like the fact that it's on my
[ __ ] phone I'll take it anywhere I
want to go but I I invest in something
called REITs do you know what REITs are
oh oh yeah yeah so it stands for real
estate investment trusts so rather than
buying one piece of property imagine if
you owned you're a whole condominium
unit but just a piece of it like a stock
but of Real Estate so you can diversify
with that am I blowing your mind a
little bit right a little bit Yeah okay
well we could talk we could sidebar on
this all right all right all right so
fascinating so um but what's your
biggest money lesson for young people
out there because you've made money bro
if you're saying you dropped 800 Grand
an apartment you're not like I don't
know I just found 800 Grand on the floor
one day but that money is gone you know
that's the problems people it's not gone
it's in it's in real in a real estate
ass that's a good point so what's your
best advice when it comes to money
uh I think I think you should listen to
people you should invest you should if
you don't get it get someone who does
get it you know because if you're not
going to figure it out then then get the
help and uh yeah I think buy stuff
uh and listen to people and have a job
that makes money yeah that's true well
you know they try to do something with
your money you know actually do you know
that what your best asset is like what's
your number one asset that you that you
have probably that apartment yeah you're
wrong oh you want to know what your
number one asset is my brain yes bro
your your ability to make money by
telling [ __ ] jokes all right because
you could earn 100 Grand a year whatever
a half a million bucks a year a million
bucks a year and all of a sudden your
800 Grand little apartment who gives a
[ __ ] about that it's your ability to
make sure that you can continually make
income that's your number one asset
there you go I like you are your most
important asset Mark Norman wow I wish
you were my dad yeah well what were your
sizes doing that 10-year grind I did
everything I was a temp which I hated I
worked as a uh what do you call a
registrar at a school so I had to kick
kids out for being like not attending
enough classes that was a nightmare uh I
know I moved furniture for years I
worked on a construction site and then
uh the best gig janitor
I'm gonna say like janitor yeah what's
the best job for a comedian that's
comedy adjacent but the truth is
anything life is gonna help you with
your material so any kind of job it
doesn't really matter it's not like with
an actor you know you want to do
something it's like real estate or what
you're saying because it's in front of
people but comedy you just need to be
somewhere you can observe life happens
yes yeah totally I gotta you're a fan of
Always Sunny in Philadelphia yeah it's
like my favorite show you ever seen the
episode where Charlie Day Charlie is the
janitor no oh dude you gotta watch that
especially if you were a janitor he's
given kids advice he's breaking up
fights he's you know he's telling the
principal all he goes into the principal
yeah the kid was real dirty so I took
him to the showers the game and showers
like you gave the kid a shower what are
you doing what was it like being a
janitor I loved it because uh I mean
sure you're cleaning up [ __ ] you're
you're pulling a possum out of the uh
ventilation duct and [ __ ] actually yeah
well it was a rat but yeah uh so that
part sucked but I had my headphones in
all day I was thinking about jokes I was
a broke comedian just trying to make it
I would go in the boiler room for lunch
and write for an hour every day that was
like my big thing and you know head down
no brain power nothing worse than
answering the phone getting yelled at
hey one short one billion dollars short
of a million dollars all that [ __ ] and
yeah you know the elevator and then
bullshitting with the other uh employees
is a nightmare so I think everybody
thought I was a heroin addict uh like
why is this kid mopping floors what's
his deal he must have killed a guy or
something so how old were you at the
time when you did that I was probably
like 25. okay yeah you know good looking
white boy janitor they're like he's
clearly doing drugs yeah so it turns out
it was I was addicted to math it was a
problem that's funny dude yeah so great
gig okay well why do you ask that
question about a comedy adjacent jobs
well you said you know the best advice
is to do a job that makes you money so
obviously comedy is not that for the
next 10 years for me so I'm just trying
to figure out what I can do that will
still that will still nurture the comedy
brain like you said if you you need a
job that um doesn't take up too much of
the storage in your yes mind because all
my best jokes are doing like when I'm
doing menial tasks and I'm not thinking
that's when something comes to me so
right what for this next 10-year Journey
what can I do to make money that is
still gonna facilitate the the dream
that I can go out and do the gigs at
night yeah and have to wake up early for
a nine to five cool you want to keep
that night free that's the key the night
has to be free yeah we've got about a
half hour level we're gonna take calls
at the end of you do we have time for
calls yeah we do that okay cool I'll
have to leave the studio though oh God
no John you've been killing it so far I
don't know if we need you to leave but
maybe we'll do calls like around like 3
50 and then we can wrap up right at four
and then boom we're gonna have a great
time we'll go get drunk
um before we transition to more dating
type stuff like that do you have like
one comedy uh one money joke that comes
to mind I've heard you say something
about like
um gay people and broke people have a
lot in common
like gay people uh is that something
that comes to mind yeah gave people uh
and and poor people have a lot in common
uh you know we're born that way
uh our parents are just gonna go you try
to tell your parents to go yeah we know
[Music]